so you want to play quantum break but
you don't have an xbox one no problem
Remedy Entertainment confirmed that it's
also coming to PC even better you can
get the windows 10 version for free by
pre-ordering the game by April fourth
quantum break doesn't support
cross-platform play but you will be able
to transfer saves between console and PC
and remedy is handling the pc version
themselves you can check out the full
list of recommended specs on gamespot on
top of that quantum break includes
remedies last game Alan Wake and both of
its DLC add-ons pre-order at
participating retailers and you'll also
get a free download of the standalone
expansion alan wake's american nightmare
and if you don't own an xbox one you can
always pick up the quantum break bundle
which includes a white 500 gigabyte
console the game and the Alan Wake
extras but there are plenty of goodies
no matter how you decide to pick up the
game quantum break hits xbox one and pc
on april fifth so you have right up
until the last minute to grab that free
Windows 10 version and if you're keeping
track of all the announcements from
reberty and Microsoft you're already in
the right place
you